viactive ça me permet de rencontrer des
gens de sortir pour retrouver le chemin
de l'emploi
pour moi au départ c'était vraiment
l'idée de me re créer un réseau depuis
un an c'est la promesse faite aux
bénéficiaires du rsa dans le haut rhin
pas d'obligation quelques centaines de
missions proposées et presque autant de
volontaires mais cela fonctionne t-il
vraiment on penser qu'on a un regard du
travail ce matin près d'un an maintenant
que christelle brender burget à intégrer
le dispositif quatre heures de bénévolat
tous les mercredis pour animer des
ateliers pour enfants une activité dont
elle espère aujourd'hui faire son métier
très important que ça reste sous le
biais des volontariats peut-être sans y
avait obligé ils oracle a été aussi
bénéfique pour moi j'aurais pas appris
autant j'aurais pas votre avis
initialement pourtant le haut-rhin
voulait conditionner le rsa la
réalisation de sept heures de bénévolat
décision polémique avait soulevé la
contestation avant d'être annulé par la
justice
finalement c'est un système basé sur le
volontariat qui a été mis en place
résultat depuis un an 800 contrats
d'engagement bénévole signé apparemment
bien peu face aux dix sept mille 200
bénéficiaires du rsa dans le haut rhin
sur les dix-sept mille deux cents foyers
clairement 7000 ne sont pas très
éloignées
d'un point donc l'objectif c'est
d'accompagner dans un premier temps
c'est 7000 allocataires pour leur
permettre de retrouver dans les le plus
rapidement possible en emploi et pour y
arriver le bénévolat n'est qu'un outil
parmi d'autres que thierry collet a
saisi au vol
nous avions rencontré cet ancien
cuisinier alors qu'il débutait son
bénévolat dans une association
d'alphabétisation
un engagement qui après quatre ans de rs
albi a ouvert une autre voie désormais
il donne quelques heures d'initiation au
numérique rémunérés dans une association
d'insertion
c'est vraiment ce qui m'a permis encore
une fois de rencontrer des gens de créer
un nouveau réseau puis de me trouver les
nouveaux centres d'intérêts
c'est ce qui m'a le plus séduit le fait
que le bénévolat y avait permis de
développer ses compétences qui étaient
de faire à s'y rendre pour moi et qui me
permettait de lui confier immédiatement
une équipe en étant certains qui
seraient transférés sans savoir
aujourd'hui le conseil d'état a tranché
du bénévolat peut bien être demandées
aux bénéficiaires du rsa mais dans le
haut-rhin pas question pour l'heure de
revenir sur le principe du volontariat